I think that we will always be no
because of our Constitution are kind of
unique commitment to freedom and
equality even if it's been imperfect
over you know the few hundred years the
kind of march toward that more perfect
union and the the individualism and the
chance for individuals to make a go of
it is something that's been a magnet for
immigrants and the immigrant imagination
and really the world imagination I think
that's all powerful I think I think
where we've hit the wall is that in
economic terms just as a matter of
reality the age of American
exceptionalism is coming to an end you
know the post-war period when we were
the only economy left standing and we've
had a great run for 50 65 years that was
you know that can't last forever and as
these other nations rise up from
humanity's point of view it's a
wonderful thing you've got hundreds of
millions of people being lifted out of
poverty in China and India and as they
as they rise that'll be you know they'll
have they'll make greater calls for
freedom you know a lot of the ideals
that we cherish will be realized abroad
when those folks have a better economic
toehold but we just have to realize that
we're not calling the shots and we're
not in is much control uniquely of our
economic destiny as we used to be that's
kind of a it's a sort of a growing up
that we have to do because the period
since world war two was in some sense an
exception itself you know we found
ourselves in this unique situation it
doesn't mean we won't still be an
incredible world leader and a powerful
force for good through the power of
ideals but I think that the fact that
that year is ending where we stood
astride the global loan economically
means that we just have to rethink some
of the way we decide we want to have a
decent society and I think in particular
the fact that the fact that we were on
top for so long in this way has led us
as a culture to overestimate the power
of the individual to shape his own
economic destiny in a way that I think
now is going to require some rebalancing
and I think that one of the one of the
things we'll see then in the ear ahead
is that there are things we have to do
as a community like basic health
coverage we have to make sure is a
commune
unity that that's something that every
American enjoys and not just leave it to
the kind of random whim of whether you
happen to work for a large employer who
offers that you know those are some of
the kind of dead ideas that just won't
make sense in an era when when we're
competing globally against all these
other countries